a pistol with over 100 years of service
a weapon that boasts some of the most
numerous appearances in movies TV and
video games we are here at the Royal
armories in Leeds with keeper of arms
and artillery Jonathan Ferguson to sit
down and talk through the history of the
1911. from its invention through two
world wars and the modern day as well as
the legacy of this Century old handgun
as it remains an iconic weapon both in
reality and in our video games
let's go
foreign
911 is probably one of the most old and
iconic weapons both in reality pop
culture movies TV video games tabletop
games Comics books because it's been
around for so long it's been in
everything but can you give us a little
history about this gun yeah of course I
mean the the designation is the giveaway
fairly the year 1911. you know I
remember the 2011 Centenary of this
thing now I feel old it's official uh
name was was the cult Government Model
hasn't really caught on people don't
tend to call it that M1911 is strictly
the US military designation and it
emerged from the U.S pistol Trials of
1907 the US military was looking for a
self-loading pistol primarily they only
had three revolvers I think it was in
that trial and all of those guns look
Antiquated now this thing just doesn't
this is a classic piece of industrial
design this sounds pretentious but it
has a sculptural quality to it I think
you're allowed to sound Pretenders if
you want to yeah if guns can be
beautiful I think the 1911 depending
which one we have a few on the table
this one uh maybe not that one uh I
think you can call it beautiful now tied
strongly into that trial was the
ammunition today you would start with
your requirements then your ammunition
and then you develop the weapon and that
was true here for not the first time
perhaps but it's quite early for that so
that 45 automatic Colt pistol cartridge
which is what we end up with uh 230
grains of weight which is a lot
traveling at 800 feet per second I still
thinking uh Imperial because of the guns
that was a hell of a round for that time
the round is just as important as the
gun and they nearly always go together
because that I think is the uh argument
that you hear a lot which isn't doesn't
really matter in in video games and
movies that comparison between nine
millimeter and 45 and you know there's a
lot of games that don't even get into
that either they don't really have huge
swings in like damage stats or anything
like that between a 45 caliber or like a
nine millimeter Glock or Beretta which
is correct by the way I mean I will be
challenged on that but the all handgun
rounds are much of a muchness especially
if you can use expanding ammunition as
Special Operations forces and law
enforcement can they all expand to the
same diameter they all do the same
amount of damage so carry more rounds
this is still an issue to some police
and the Marines still use a variant of
it things like that they still have them
I'm not sure that they're still using
them very much I haven't seen one in any
photos or footage for a while they're
using things like Glock 19s alongside
them I'd get a strong sense that that is
they're clinging to tradition with that
thing and I don't think it'll be much
longer but even if it isn't that's a
heck of a run
the ergonomics of a modern pistol again
they come from this the magazine catch
falling under the thumb the slide
release or you know again falls under
the thumb so does the safety the sort of
unitary slide and Barrel Arrangement
everything that followed copied this
just to compare so this is the model
1905 and it was variants of this that
were entered into that trial I mentioned
so it almost looks like a slightly wrong
1911 compared yeah you can see where
they were going from the earlier
blockier designs like the Colt 1902 with
it with a disassembly wedge at the front
here
rather a straight grip to that perfectly
angled for many people pistol grip now
you can just Trace so much back to this
thing and I think that sort of implied
argument I think about stopping power I
think that people even if they're sort
of surface level aware of that argument
might attribute more stopping power to
this pistol even if you say it's not
accurate and I think that well there's
truth to it in armed forces of nation
states that aren't special operation
sources or something have to use what we
call ball ammunition Full Metal Jacket
it can't be expanding or anything so the
only way to increase so-called stopping
power with a pistol you can't get the
velocity high enough to make any real
difference but you can increase the
diameter of the bullet so compared to a
38 revolver cartridge a 45 made sense in
1911. so there's truth to the stopping
power argument it's just kind of been
overtaken by technology and events it's
easily if not in the top five of the top
10 firearm that's appeared in the most
sort of bits of of Cinema or pop culture
even back in 1918 it was appearing in
propaganda films and then it's still in
games that are coming out this year it's
a legacy in reality and in pop culture
is enormous for the whole of the 20th
century the very least this was the
pistol if you're going to depict a
pistol I had an inquiry only yesterday
from somebody wanting to know what
pistol was being represented in some
panels of an old Batman comic and it was
highly stylized but it was one of these
gangster movies war movies it was a bit
too late for the old west
but just about everything else if you
ask them to draw a pistol as a
self-loading pistol as opposed to a
revolver I suspect they'd Draw Something
Like This yeah I'd not even thought
about that but I think you're you're
right that is because of its prominence
in pop culture there the silhouette that
people imagine and what's interesting is
because of that as that Fame has grown
and and the ability to depict it has has
changed into video games and the like
it's been in a lot of Firsts I mean it's
in terms of video games like the first
medal of honor I think that's the the
first Big World War II game in a 3D
environment First Call of Duty the first
Battlefield it's entrance into virtual
environments is incredible and I think
it carries that history with it but it's
a little bit of a shame is that as video
games have developed that sort of damage
Trope has sort of gone away when you're
playing a multiplayer shooter quite
often 15 rounds of nine millimeter that
do maybe slightly less damage but you're
still in most online Arenas gonna kill
in in the same number of shots it's not
a lot of point in carrying the the 1911
so through in the real world of all of
the things that have a reflection in
reality I think that's one of the most
valid ones a slightly bigger bullet
making a very slightly bigger hole in
somebody is not going to make any
practical difference it's much more
important way you hit them we've talked
before about weapons that are sort of
more video gamey than they are cinematic
this is a very cinematic weapon I feel
like is it the Kimber version that
appears in John Wick Kimber 1911 45 ACP
true
seven round capacity John Mike was given
a pistol with less bullets but all the
more opportunities to do those Wick
flicks
you'll get you'll get less quick flicks
with the 15 Ram 900 magazine yeah I mean
my only criticism of the John Wick
movies is he reloads too much I mean
it's because he's only got It's
regardless of what it is you know he has
extended magazines and he he replaces
them far too quickly and I know why it's
because in there they watch the dailies
that's an awesome reload we build that
into the narrative that we create in
editing don't pay slavish attention to
how many rounds he fires sometimes they
do
that's a very sort of modern example of
its appearance in cinema but throw a
dart at a board of iconic sort of
anywhere from 70s action movies to early
2000s you throw a dart at all those
movies you're gonna hit a movie that has
the 1911 in it's heat Al Pacino he's
chosen that weapon because he thinks
it's a good weapon Ronin Sean Bean makes
the you know remarks oh it's an old gun
yeah I actually figured the old 1911.
45
all gone criticizing the old man's
choice of gun but he's the quiet
professional that gets the job done it
that's you know there's so many ways to
use firearms in narrative fashion
absolutely in the hands of the
Terminator that's a good gun yeah giant
robot designed to kill for a T800 why
does a Terminator with perfect
coordination and vision need a laser
sight uh or a 45 handgun for that matter
he doesn't it's a it's a purely
narrative thing but it looks the
business the laser sight reflects his
own technological basis it doesn't
matter that doesn't make sense it's
embodying his robot nature before you
get to see that he's a robot it's all
genius James Cameron and stuff for sure
and then you know Saving Private Ryan I
still remember the scene when Tom Hanks
characters shooting a tank with it and
when I first watched that scene I
genuinely thought he blew up the tank
with the pistol and then I was very
young and I watched it and I was like a
plane just flew overhead
[Music]
yeah if I have one criticism without
scene it's the I think you want to be
able to see the impact
on the hull of the tank maybe he's
missing he's very injured
it's a big Target
which is an amazing scene yeah
absolutely and even so like you're
saying World War II constant appearance
twisting it into sci-fi It just fits
everywhere every Vietnam movie every
Vietnam game like I was saying even in
comics like The Punisher carries it
because he was a marine and that was his
issued weapon in Vietnam it's another
gun that I think just the Aesthetics and
recognizability allow it to be twisted
into different modes well and I think
we've talked about this before in terms
of science fiction the best science
fiction I feel are ones that are
grounded in reality things that are
recognizable and that is something that
I think the the 1911 lens even if you
know there are versions
like this that are more
Romeo and Juliet than they are Saving
Private Ryan I think we even have a uh a
dragon slayer 1911 here with a engraved
dragon on the slide and the word dragon
slayer
on the rear of the side just in case you
were in any doubt but even so like the
more esoteric games that allow you to do
things like this or you're firing them
at zombies There's precedent in real
world yeah I was wondering whether or
not you feel its popularity is sort of
carried because there's such American
Pride in this firearm that they want it
in their Cinema they want it in
obviously their propaganda but then in
comics in newsreels and TV and games
because it is I think a firearm that
American Gun enthusiasts are very proud
of that's true but it has a strong
tradition elsewhere there's the
Argentine uh balliston Molina variant
you know the RFC in 1917 had 1911s we
have them in the collection and in 1918
when the RF was created they are stamped
RAF it was recognized as a very good
design early on and so other countries
adopted it but you definitely can't get
away from from just how American it is
like we said you know it might be
falling out of favor in some elements in
the world and even if their virtual
representations are mixed I can't
imagine ever not seeing this firearm on
our screens neither can I um and they're
you know they're so robust that they're
going to be physically around for a long
time like the AK
see you in Fallout 5 1911.
[Music]